[Musik]
sind
hallo herr zum kabel satellit welt heute
gibt es eine richtig tolle und leckere
vom export ich habe eine schokoladen hin
werte mit einer maskat ohne qualen
gebacken und die torte sieht wirklich
sehr feines und wedelt und die in der
herstellung wirklich super super einfach
der boden das ist ein biscuit darunter
oder dazwischen besser gesagt die matt
capone quark mit vanille freinacht und
dazwischen habe ich noch eine
himbeeressig und so eine richtig tolle
fruchtige schicht oben habe ich die
torte mit etwas kakaopulver mattiert und
so finde ich diese einfach edel und fein
aus und die kommt wirklich ohne viel
deko aus das heißt hier haben wir eine
native cache und ich finde da kann sich
wirklich auch jeder sonntags passend
sehen lassen
ich werde jetzt einmal sagen weil die
torte ist supereinfach ist starte ich
direkt und weil ich mal die zutaten für
den witzig für den hilfskredit brauch
ich für einen heißen espresso oder fiel
es leicht mit wasser etwas vanille
extrakt eine tonkabohne eine prise salz
120 gramm zucker jeweils 50 gramm mehl
speisestärke und kakaopulver und zwei
teelöffel backpulver zuerst einmal nicht
die eier und weiß es am besten wenn die
zimmer waren sind zu lassen sich nämlich
viel einfacher aufschlagen
da gebe ich jetzt an den extrakt dazu
jetzt kann ich sie nur ein bisschen da
braucht man wirklich nur ganz wenig
einen halben teelöffel etwa da stecken
nämlich echte vanilleschoten drin dann
einen heißen espresso und wenn ihr kein
es versuchsreihen seite nimmt einfach
heißes wasser habe ich noch eine prise
salz und tonkabohne dafür natürlich
glaube ich sogar zum ersten mal im video
und tonkabohne riecht ein bisschen
weihnachtlich eigentlich aber zu der tat
passt auch echt ganz gut und wissen
gewirkt und normalerweise bekommen wir
das auch in gut sortierten wieso
menschen mit kreide oder andere mini
reibe dafür und al gore und ganz ganz
kleines stückchen darf und dafür auch
wirklich nicht gefiel versenken
da kommt jetzt noch dass zucker mit rein
und die masse lass es jetzt für etwas
vierte 5 oder auch sechs minuten cremig
verrühren bis die eier und der zucker so
richtig schön staubig und fast schon
steigt also richtig stabil musste mache
sein
[Musik]
feiern sie perfekt wirklich schön
schaumig cremig und wie gesagt hast
steif aber ganz feierlich 21 ereignet
mit nämlich die masse hier auf und
braucht es die küchenmaschine auch nicht
mehr
ihr könnt natürlich das ganze auch im
handwerk gerät machen aber es dauert ein
bisschen länger und ihrem versuch die
ganze zeit dabei stehen aber mit dem
handrührgerät kann es natürlich bei über
10 bis 15 minuten dauern
jetzt nämlich ein betrieb und da kommen
jetzt die trockenen zutaten mit beiden
[Musik]
die werde ich jetzt mit dem schneebesen
einfach vorsichtig unterheben
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die bizkit master in den
vorbereiteten tortenring und den habe
ich jetzt bereits auf 24 zentimeter
eingestellt und den stelle ich schon
immer gerne auf die dauer back folie und
auf mein perforiert das backblech und
bekommt der bis jetzt in den
vorgeheizten backofen bei 190 grad ober
unterhitze für ungefähr 25 minuten und
danach muss ich ihn komplett abkühlen
lassen
david ist jetzt gebacken ich habe auch
mit stäbchen truppe gemacht und ihn
jetzt zum abkühlen auf ein apfel gitter
gesetzt
und da ist auch schon komplett abgekühlt
das heißt ich kann ihn zumal die spülung
vorbereiten und sag ich hier die zutaten
für die füllung brauche ich 350 gramm
frische oder gefrorene himbeeren 30
gramm zucker
ich habe ich fünf aggregate sind uns
sämtliche mittel und für die creme
brauch ich 500 gramm magerquark bei 150
grad ab ohne 400 gramm schlagsahne 10
teelöffel sommerparty 60 gramm
puderzucker und etwas mit sex
praktiziert in bern bereits in einen
topf geben und einfach auftauen lassen
ihr könnt euch auch frische himbeeren
verwenden aber die tiefgefrorenen die
sie noch immer richtig schön reibt jetzt
habe ich diesen bisschen durchgedrückt
also ich hab dir nicht püriert sondern
einfach unterdrückt und jetzt kann ich
sie passieren fast durch ein sieb
streichen damit die kerne weg in ihr
könnt ihr natürlich auch drin lassen
aber ich hab di gern bei der torte
lieber weg
[Musik]
hab alles schon gut rausgekommen
jetzt muss die kerne übrig und die frau
ist erst einmal nichts mehr kommen zur
seite und jetzt nämlich dass fruchtpüree
und geht es hier wieder in den topf da
kommen wir sogar mit dazu ihr könnt ihn
auch weglassen ist einfach mal schauen
wie süß oder sauer die ihren vielen
wären drin und es kommt noch dass acker
mit rein pflanzlichen geliermittel und
es nämlich immer anstelle von ballack
der das ganze zwar gehört und dann wird
aufgekocht und dann muss ich zwei
minuten lang sprudelnd kochen lassen und
wehren befüllung hier jetzt noch kocht
kann ich schon mal die creme zu bereiten
das heißt ich gebe zumal die sahne in
einer wertung gemeinsam mit dem us
capone und dann lasse ich das ganze bei
niedriger stufe kurz berühren bis
mascarpone und sahne schön verbunden
sind
[Musik]
und sobald die masse gut verrührt ist
komme ich aus seiner partei
und dann schlag ich prima zur pole mit
der sahne zusammen schreibt
[Musik]
nehmt war kann ich jetzt hier in der
größeren schüssel drin und jetzt kommt
der fotodrucker mit rein und man ihr
extrakt und dann kann ich das ganz kurz
verrühren
[Musik]
dann kommt der quark mit sahne und quark
der macht die sahne auch jetzt schön
leicht also dadurch schmeckt die trotte
einfach sehr erfrischend jetzt kann
alles noch ganz gut verrührt werden
damit vielleicht auch nicht so lange
wird von mir die sanis einfachen
schritten die creme ist fertig die
stelle ich gleich in den kühlschrank und
kann jetzt hier schon mal sich in der
masse in einen teller für so kühl sie
einfach ein bisschen schneller ab und
die sollte man etwa lauwarmen werden
also nicht zu heißen die sahne und in
der zwischenzeit kann ich schon in
bizkit nehmen und zweimal durchschneiden
[Musik]
jetzt habe ich den bizkit
durchgeschnitten und den deckel nehme
ich jetzt als boden weil ich später
nämlich den flachen boden was decken
möchte weil er einfach ein schöner
abschluss ist jetzt kann ich dir nehmen
und dann könnt ihr zum beispiel espresso
nehmen oder ihn im team bergers oder
sonst irgendwie und könnte den boden
damit franken wenn ihr möchtet macht es
also in unser morabito und jetzt kommt
es hier wieder ein bug ring drumherum
deswegen findet ihr auch super praktisch
weil ich sie zum backen verwendet und
später eben auch vom befüllen der torte
darüber kommt jetzt die hälfte quark
sahne creme und weil es später eine ecke
torte wird mittels aufpassen dass der
anti raucher fucking immer schön sauber
bleibt
[Musik]
doch mal gespielt hat so wie ich jetzt
hier könnt ihr einfach eine peitsche
aber nehmen und hier kommt jetzt das
himbeer fruchtpüree darüber und fenster
und wenn ihr meister nimmt eine gabel
und könnte von bisschen marmorieren
jetzt kommt ihr der mittlere boden drauf
und dann wird der ganze vorgang noch mal
wiederholt
[Musik]
und zum schluss kaum der deckel drauf
ganz vorsichtig und dann schön flach
drücken und den werde ich auch noch mal
trinken und dann fällig die torte in den
kühlschrank und kann derzeit schon mal
die köpfe der gäste
[Musik]
für die zart beta das habe ich jetzt 400
milliliter sahne
die kommt direkt in einen topf und die
lanciert aufkochen und dann habe ich
noch 100 gramm tafel schokolade bereits
fein gehackt ihr könnt ihr zarter
schokolade oder auch kuvertüre nehmen
oder auch was eigentlich mein besonderes
highlight und mein liebling ist herrin
schokolade aber ich habe nicht gesehen
was sich um alle etwa uns hat neulich
anscheinend ganz viel herren schokolade
verbraucht daher liegt oder schokolade
und sobald die sahne kocht stechen
heraus
dann kommt da wie schokolade mit rein
und die kann ich das hier etwa zwei
minuten stehen datum wann ich will
und dann will ich durch
[Musik]
jetzt will ich die gar schritt um damit
sie ganz leicht abkühlen kann aber
dennoch schön warm und schön fliesen
sein und dann kommt die mannschaft toll
dass ich ihn habe ich jetzt ein paar mal
auf die arbeitsminister geklopft
bekommen einfach die luft nach oben und
platzen
und jetzt kann ich locker noch einmal
auf die torte gebucht während im drehen
verteilt schließlich standen
[Musik]
jetzt kommt ihr der deckel drauf und
jetzt will ich die tafel für mindestens
4 stunden im kühlschrank
die torte sitzen fest geworden jetzt
löst sich den torten rand bevor ich die
dauer wegnehme bestreitet einfach
überrannt von bisher mit kakaopulver
so wird die oberfläche leicht markiert
[Musik]
also der kakao will wie ich der macht
die ganze klasse und jetzt sehe ich erst
mal die torte auf meine schöne fahrten
platte
merkel
[Musik]
und jetzt können wir beispielsweise
seinen taten ein zahlenwerk und auch 16
markierungen und den drücke ich hier
ganz leicht ein
und so kann ich die tortenstücke
gekennzeichnet
hier noch ein paar hin bayern und die
werde ich jetzt noch obendrauf
[Musik]
jetzt kann ich die torte anschneiden
das natürlich super praktisch mit den
linien her
statiker hat jetzt schon zu meinem
geburtstag
zumindest optisch dann wieder auf sich
egal was mich aber jetzt sehen sich hier
zumindest die verzichten und war wie
breite schichten die wirklich sehr
saftig sind dazwischen wie zweiten
mangelt quarks und hier oben drauf und
das finde ich ganz schön die frucht dann
so leicht ein leichter effekt haben und
ich denke ich probiere einfach so murat
hat nämlich noch nicht geschafft das mit
zu hause bei der arbeit und ich darf
probieren
die sprache ist nicht zu viel schokolade
[Musik]
mit oben mit einem karton aber die
frucht ist der hammer ich habe noch
überlegt mache ich mir hin werte mit
weißer schokolade und dachten die dunkle
schokolade hat mich doch schon wieder da
bin ich schwach geworden und das ist
einfach echt die perfekte torte wirklich
super leicht so vereinfacht und
schokoladig rookies alles in einem
vor allem die läufer von den himbeeren
die dunkle schokolade und in creme oder
mega man sagt aber hallo
und das noch nicht probiert nicht
probier doch gabel ist bereits 8000
stück ist für dichtere haben also falls
ihr auch in genuss dieser leckeren
torten kommen wollt dann solltet ihr
wirklich auch mein blog update mit blogs
das rezept sofort ausdrucken oder online
anschauen
die zutaten holen und dann gleich mit
der vorbereitung anfangen die torte ist
supereinfach in der herstellung super
lecker und ich wünsche euch jetzt mal
ganz viel spaß dabei und bis zum
nächsten mal seit langem so hoch ist wie
kommen wir da hin oh mein gott
[Musik]
hau rein
mehr
[Musik]